un petit point
avec les publics
[Musique]
des réseaux
parce que sans cela évidemment
on est bien peu de choses
hello la commune
juste un petit poste pour vous dire que
là je vais remettre le César 2023 du
meilleur acteur dans un second rôle je
suis hyper content ça sera sans moment
il s'agira de se mettre un peu en
retrait j'espère que ça va bien se
passer j'espère surtout réussir à être à
la hauteur
excusez-moi être à la hauteur puisque
comme vous le savez pour ceux qui ont
suivi mon poste du oui décembre je suis
diagnostiqué il prend sensible n'en
déplaise
osceptiques c'est le stade au-dessus de
l'hypersensibilité donc vraiment
j'essaye de tenir pour ouvrir
l'enveloppe du petit loulou qui aura
gagné la queue du Mickey ce soir pardon
j'espère aussi ne pas être trop distant
être dans le bon rapport puisque comme
vous le savez et vos témoignages m'ont
tellement apporté tellement fait grandir
merci je suis aussi vous le savez un
profil non pas HPI est non ça serait
trop simple mais HLM hi lève online au
niveau d'esprit c'est américain c'est
une sorte de trouble invisible qui à
cause de mes trop grandes capacités et
j'en suis désolé me rend un peu froid
extérieurement alors qu'à l'intérieur à
l'intérieur c'est la sot cadence dans
mon cœur
donc là
donc là les loulous je vais ouvrir
l'enveloppe est-ce que je m'effondre et
ce que je suis une marbre est-ce que je
m'effondre où est-ce que je pète un
plomb incapable de vous le dire pour
l'instant c'est encore trop tôt on verra
au moment de l'enveloppe voilà les
amours j'y passe pas trois heures je
déteste parler de moi comme vous le
savez me mettre en avant très peu pour
moi juste mais pour m'aimer vous le
savez pour mes mais moi-même et ben ça
commence par moi-même comme le dit la
main qui regarde les étoiles j'adore les
Indiens serez-moi les pouces je vous
adore et bien sûr je vous envoie tout à
l'heure une photo du dessert
voilà alors envoyer
hashtag je vous aime hashtag trophées
cinéma de France
#te un problème
#tavi pas la mienne